Baking this loaf is a tasty way to use up those overly ripe bananas.
You will need one and a half cups of all-purpose flour,...
...one teaspoon of baking soda, one teaspoon of baking powder,...
..one-quarter teaspoon of salt, two large eggs, one cup of sugar,...
..one half cup of vegetable oil, three to four bananas, mashed, one and a half cups,...
...and one teaspoon of vanilla.
Equipment: a metal loaf pan and a cooling rack.
Optional: a pinch of cinnamon, three-quarters of a cup of walnuts...
...and three-quarters of a cup of chocolate chips.
Step 1: Preheat oven to 350 degrees Fahrenheit.
Grease and flour the loaf pan.
Step 2: Sift the flour, baking soda, and salt into a bowl.
Add a pinch of cinnamon if you like.
Step 3: Beat the eggs and sugar with an electric mixer...
...or whisk on medium until well blended, about six minutes.
Step 4: Gradually mix in the oil, and then the bananas and vanilla.
Step 5: Fold in the sifted flour mixture with a wooden spoon.
Add walnuts or chocolate chips, or a combination of both, if you like.
Step 6: Pour into the loaf pan and bake until a toothpick stuck in the center comes out clean, ...
...an hour to an hour and 15 minutes.
Step 7: Let it cool for ten minutes before removing from pan...
...and cooling completely on a rack.
Did you know?
A cluster of bananas is called a hand...
...and consists of ten to 20 bananas, which are known as fingers.